now we did have goldman sachs ceo david
solomon you know he's been djing a lot
but he went on uh he went on cnbc this
morning one he said bitcoin and uh
ethereum i don't own either one of them
okay second thing he said was uh i have
no opinion about them
okay and the third thing was basically
uh we like blockchain technology and
we're gonna go because we like
digitization of uh of finance let me get
this straight with a multi-billion
dollar financial institution you're the
ceo the most important person the key
decision maker this is the fastest
growing segment of finance it's the
fastest growing adoption of any
financial technology in history it's
gone from zero to a trillion dollars
some of these assets are worth more than
your entire bank and you have no opinion
even if you hate it or you love it or
you're anywhere in between no opinion
come on i don't think very many people
believe that and if you told me that hey
look he's trying to be politically
correct he's trying to actually prevent
having to put out an opinion because
he's negative against it and somebody
internally said hey maybe you don't want
to be negative or bearish on these
assets in public that's fine but i don't
think anyone's sitting at home listening
to the ceo of goldman sachs say that
they have no opinion on the fastest
growing segment of their industry the
most disruptive sector literally people
are quitting their jobs at goldman sachs
to go and work in this industry you have
no opinion maybe you need to get an
opinion to actually stop the bleeding
and go ahead and make sure you embrace
the technology so you don't get
disrupted i mean goldman sachs went from
being a 100 billion dollar bank to 130
billion over the last decade bitcoin
went from zero to a trillion
so like you're getting laughed buddy you
might want to start paying attention
yeah and by the way i actually don't
believe that they believe what they're
saying i do believe that if you're the
ceo of a large uh institution you have
to appease your legacy clients because
they make up the bulk of your revenue
today and you don't get points for being
right in advance
in the market
on your balance sheet nobody said oh he
was bullish on bitcoin early right and
so therefore he gets points you do
however lose clients if you start
talking about something that ends up
going to zero if you're known as the
bitcoin guy or the ethereum guy or the
crypto guy or whatever and you're out
there on public uh national television
talking about this stuff and then it
ends up going to zero all of a sudden
clients are calling up and they're
saying hey man you know you're supposed
to be the risk mitigation here you're
supposed to be protecting my assets
you're supposed to uh be the
conservative guy in the room what are
you doing talking about this stuff that
ended up being a zero
so at some point it's a career
protection and a legacy business
protection and you can still go operate
and build this stuff we know that
goldman sachs has a team that's working
on this stuff so ultimately what they're
saying one thing but they're doing
something else just look at what they're
doing obviously they're bullish on this
stuff somebody in the business maybe
it's not uh solomon maybe somebody else
but somebody is bullish on it in the
business because they actually have a
team dedicated to working on this stuff
and it's just a question of what are
they going to do when they're going to
do it how successful it's not really
surprising to me that he doesn't own it
though i don't know i think like because
at the end of the day like is it really
going to uh like does it provide that
much upside for him you know what i mean
like yeah sure owning the asset is
important understanding is important all
that kind of stuff but i feel like it
adds legitimacy to it from his
perspective that is not unneeded for him
personally right like he's already the
ceo of a massive bank he's super wealthy
he doesn't need to uh make sure he's at
this new frontier right from a business
standpoint yes you absolutely need to be
concerned about all this kind of stuff
but personally you know i don't think he
manages his own portfolio right most of
it's probably made up of equity within
uh financial services and things that he
operates in so it's not really
surprising that he doesn't own the
assets specifically because at the end
of the day that just opens up the door
for many more questions people ask him a
bunch of different things and people to
assume his position on rather than
actually listen to him so the other
thing that's important here is uh when
you don't have a massive balance sheet
so let's say the everyday american you
have to be early because you need tons
and tons of asymmetry right in order to
kind of change your financial position
these large asset managers don't need to
be first they just need to be right and
what i mean by that is uh let's use
somebody let's use anthony scaramucci
and skybridge as an example right
anthony scaramucci i would say was
cautiously optimistic he was like look i
don't really understand this completely
it sounds interesting there's a lot of
smart people working on it but i'm going
to kind of wait and see what happens
here right and then at some point really
in kind of 2020 he got deep conviction
he said hey this is going to be a thing
we want to be at the forefront of it
we're going to go and transform our
business and so when he went ahead and
did that if i remember the numbers
correctly they bought 400 million
dollars worth of bitcoin across their uh
kind of assets and so now it's worth
about a billion dollars so if you think
of that just in kind of rounded
generalized numbers they invested 400
million they've made 600 million dollars
they've made more money on bitcoin than
almost majority if not all early
investors in bitcoin who are putting a
thousand 10 050 even a hundred thousand
dollars into bitcoin so
if you have a small balance sheet you
have to be early because you have to get
the asymmetry you have to front run the
big uh run so you need asymmetry if
you've got a large balance sheet you
don't have to do that you can put large
amount of capital to work and yes on a
multiple basis maybe he's only up you
know 250 percent
but
they have from a aggregate return
standpoint a lot of return that ends up
being outsized compared to what the
retail does